welcome back to our lying special there
are a couple purposes of lying the most
obvious is to hide what you're actually
doing but the more Sinister intent of
lying is to cause people to be terrified
and to hate each other and you see an
awful lot of that here's one example the
Florida NAACP just declared that it is
unsafe for black people to visit the
State of Florida watch this
to one of the black but quote the
country
to not come to Florida not the near
children to Florida not vacation in
Florida James new walkiel is the
president of the Lee County NAACP he
said the travel advisory is necessary in
Wake of what he called Draconian laws
targeting African Americans supported by
Governor Ron DeSantis miwakiel said if
the travel advisory hurts black business
owners like Jones it will be a sacrifice
so it's not Oakland or Gary Indiana or
Chicago this dangerous it's Florida
Byron Donalds lives in Florida in fact
he represents Florida in the United
States Congress Southwest Florida he
seems to be thriving he joins us now
Congressman thank you so much for coming
on
um I'm laughing at the absurdity of this
but what do you think the effect of
saying something like that is
I mean the effect is dangerous because
it continues this division in our
country which is absolutely ludicrous
especially in the State of Florida we're
a great state we're open to everybody we
don't want indoctrination that's clear
but we teach black history we allow
black businesses to thrive obviously I'm
thriving so many other black
professionals are thriving in Florida
this is a joke
well yeah especially because the recent
voting results in Florida show you know
lots of people of different colors
voting for the same candidate so if you
believe in an integrated Society where
race is not the most important thing
that seems to be happening in Florida
it is happening in Florida and so much
more so what the NAACP is trying to do
in my sense is trying to score political
points but they're failing frankly the
Democrat Party in Florida is failing and
it's with good reason and frankly it's a
good thing because people are choosing
Florida more and more you're seeing that
all the time
um like I can't wait to get leave DC and
get back so that's all I got to say
about it and I should also say it's just
a factual matter you represent you know
the prettiest place in Florida so you
you have extra reason to say that but it
does I do it does seem like maybe
Florida is a destination for people who
are specifically rejecting that kind of
old-fashioned rhetoric
it is well I mean what people reject um
and why they come to our state is
because one they just want to be left
alone they want their kids to actually
learn they want Common Sense policy and
they want an environment where all
people can Thrive and not be concerned
about political rhetoric indoctrination
foolishness come to the free state of
Florida it's just better
and maybe talk about race a little less
and just treat people as people
Congressman Byron Donalds of Southwest
Florida happy to have you on tonight
thank you
anytime
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight